yeah welcome to this vm playing the
truth picker from the US many Americans
today so I'm yeah the night off don't
play this slope ruby three line yeah a
for King ashwin many moves this is one
of the possible lines that d5 coming
maybe yeah but whatever you you can say
about the guy is playing very quickly
okay okay oh no 95 I just I just give
away you for this stupid should have 395
may I don't know
want to improve the the PCC Abbott the
night on b3 isn't particularly well
placed ok I'll take it you never know if
you get the chance again to to grab the
push-ups okay so mm night to see FOIA I
don't really want to take on your heart
if the Sun it looks looks awful night
see far though some tricky and this
bishop on a force somehow in a in a bad
spot maybe night to deform some yeah a
bit a bit strange this position yeah ok
I need to take with the pawn and yeah
this is curious I wouldn't I didn't
expect that at all ok so i get the
knight on d5 Oh Abel OS x on c3 now
otherwise the knight on d5 acer is
terrible mmm yeah let's go down ya know
I have to skip this funny funny position
type where the 925 is really wow I know
it's gotta be tween side as well
can Wow before as good taking is good
okay yeah I could play against the a
porno against the B porn so I went for
the ape on the nice feature is now that
the knight on d5 protects the c3 and
before so this is really the typical
octopus night mmm yeah I need to I need
to get rid of the Queens which would
help enormously Queen a for ya Queenie
phone he probably needs to exchange now
yeah this was was an alternative but i
thought i would just this impress
improved my position okay where is he
going i'm also in this long diagonal
which could prove useful
I mean queen bee five maybe a four just
a form yeah takes rook takes this cannot
do that takes rook takes rook takes
Knight f6 double check and Queen g8 made
actually cute okay he saw that probably
okay let's well let's play the end game
it's not not bad at all
look before and not sure
Jack maybe the check first to get his
King bag and then and then then cover
the palm should I cover it why is this
something better now let's commit yes
that's that's the easiest way to to go
now maybe you can play a five by ever i
have be five not a big deal cannot take
here anyway hooked rook see one
yeah I gave this check for us to make
sure Ice King assess is far far back ok
I can actually go here I want to use the
King King needs to be on d3 it will
probably give the check I just play King
III and then take h6 and at the end he
has got all week pawns and in fact where
does Luke oh this is even better the
roof doesn't have a square c6 and see a
tower answered by 97 yeah I didn't see
that before I was only thinking and rock
back and Luke age six and let's win this
end Black forfeit due to disconnection
yeah what can you do this ruke is lost
yeah it is just a very bad end game this
this this type of type of structure
maybe I had something something better
it looked at hotel alone I'm not sure
about f4 actually I mean maybe just
strengthening the position is even
better I was a bit i was a bit
captivated by this stuff I mean you
check checkmate you like those tricks
but it's it's maybe not it wasn't maybe
the the best way so I cannot why I
cannot turn the move back this is
strange I can do that but I cannot
cannot delete them yet I would like to i
would like to have analyzed this a bit
more yeah in fact here I was as
mentioned captivated by this trick but
the end came was probably good but maybe
am as a slow move here is also good
because in the game when we had
exchanged I cannot even draw him strange
when we had exchanged a five against f3c
for was a bit weak this end game would
be even better with the pawns on e5 and
f3 on the board
you know tap all right thanks for
watching